The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open Courseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT Open Courseware
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: Today is
the first of two lectures
on the rigid rotor.
And the rigid rotor is
really our first glimpse
of central force problems.
And so although the rigid rotor
is an exactly solved problem,
it's also a problem that we--
it involves something
that is universal.
If we have a spherical
object, then the angular part
of the Hamiltonian for
that spherical object
is solved by the rigid rotor.
And so if we understand
the rigid rotor
and know how to
draw pictures, we're
going to be able to
understand the universal part
of all central force problems.
So it's not just a curiosity.
It's a really major thing.
OK.
And I'm going to do a lot
of unconventional stuff
in this lecture and
the next lecture,
as far as the rigid
rotor is concerned.
Because it's covered
to death, but with lots
of equations in all textbooks.
And there is very little
effort to give you
independent insights.
And so my discussion
of the vector model
is something that I
consider really special.
And what I want you
to be able to do
is to draw cartoons
that capture essentially
all of the important points.
And that you won't find
anywhere except in my notes.
But I think it's
really important
that you have your own point
of view on these problems.
So let me just do a quick
review, with the exam in mind,
of the perturbation
theory stuff.
So we had a harmonic oscillator.
And it's perturbed by
some anharmonicity terms.
So the potential is going
to 1/2 kQ squared plus bQ
cubed plus cQ to the fourth.
And we could go on.
But this is enough.
Because it gives a glimpse
of all of the important stuff
that emerges qualitatively
as well as quantitatively
from perturbation theory.
So this is part
of the H0 problem.
And this is H1.
And so you know now that doing
second order perturbation
theory is tedious and ugly.
And it's easy to get
overwhelmed by the equations.
But what I want to
do is to just review
how you get the crucial
structure of the problem.
So the Q cubed' term--
there are no diagonal
elements of the Q cubed term.
And so we're always going to be
talking about the second order
corrections to the energy.
The selection rules are delta
v equals plus and minus 3
and plus n minus 1.
And so what I told you is, if
you're going to do the algebra,
which you probably
don't want to ever do,
you're going to want to
combine the delta v of plus 3
and minus 3 terms of
the perturbation sum.
Because the algebra simplifies.
They have similar expressions.
And you have a denominator,
which is 3 Hc omega and minus 3
Hc omega.
That factors out.
And you just have a plus 3 and
minus 3 in the denominator.
And similarly here,
so when you do this,
you lose the highest order term.
What's the highest order term?
It's v plus 1/2 to
the third power.
Because we have delta v of 3.
We have Q cubed.
And the matrix
elements of Q cubed
are a plus a-dagger cubed.
And the selection
rule for them--
or the matrix-- must go as
the square root of the power
of the a's.
And so all of the
matrix elements
have the leading term v
plus 1/2 to the 3/2 power.
But we're squaring.
And we lose the highest order
because of the subtraction.
So this one gives rise to
terms in v plus 1/2 squared.
Q4 has selection rules
delta v plus or minus 4,
plus or minus 2, and 0.
This is important.
Because this one says,
we have a contribution
from the first order--
in the first order of energy.
And so in the first
order of energy,
we're going to have v plus
1/2 to the fourth power--
I'm sorry-- to the 4/2 power.
Because we only have
the matrix element,
we don't square
the matrix element.
So this gives rise to a
term in v plus 1/2 squared.
But it's sensitive
to the sign of the Q
to the fourth term
in the Hamiltonian.
It's the only thing that's
sensitive to the sine.
We also have terms that are v
plus 1/2 to the 4/2 times 2.
So we can have matrix
elements to the four--
because it's a fourth
power term, we get 4/2.
And because it's squared,
we multiply by 2.
And then we lose
the highest order.
So we get, from this, v
plus 1/2 to the third power.
So what we're hoping to get
from the perturbation theory
is the highest order terms
in the energy expression.
And so Q to the fourth gives a
signed v plus 1/2 squared term.
And it gives an unsigned always
positive v plus 1/2 cubed term.
And this one gives v
plus 1/2 squared term.
OK.
So this would tell
you, when you're
organizing your work, what to
expect and how to organize it.
And I'm really not
expecting you to do
very much with this level of
complexity on an exam problem.
But on homework,
all bets are off.
OK.
So that's all I want to do as
far as the review is concerned.
So the rigid rotor--
we have a molecule.
So we have a bond
of length r sub 0.
And we have two masses.
And if the masses aren't
equal, the center of mass
isn't in the middle.
The center of mass--
you need to know
how to calculate where
the center of mass is.
There are all sorts
of simple algebra--
but what is
happening is this guy
is rotating without stretching
about the center of mass.
Now, what we want to do is
think about this problem
as if it were--
here's our 0.
And this is the reduced mass.
This is a motion of a
fictitious particle of mass mu.
Mu is m1 m2 over m1 plus m2
on the surface of a sphere.
They're all the same problem.
But the question is,
how do we interpret
what we get from the
solution to this problem?
So what we care about
is a description of,
where is the molecular axis?
The molecule is rotating.
And we're solving the
Schrodinger equation.
And we get things like the
expectation value of J squared
and Jz and maybe some
other things where
these are the angular momenta.
And how do the eigenfunctions
for these states--
we have a state.
And we have quantum numbers
Jm and their probability
amplitudes and theta and phi.
That's a whole lot
of stuff to digest.
We want to go as
quickly as we can
to how this is related to the
thing we really care about,
which is, where
is the bond axis?
So the molecule is rotating.
And so the bond axis is
moving in laboratory frame.
And we want to be able
to take, from that,
the minimal amount
of information
that we memorize or remember--
I don't like "memorize."
Because "memorize" doesn't
involve understanding.
But "remembering" does.
We want to be able to,
at a drop of a hat,
be able to say, yes, if
we pick these two quantum
numbers, which are related to
the eigenvalues of these two
operators, we can describe
the spatial distribution
of the molecular axis.
There is an extra complication.
So we live in the laboratory.
And we have a coordinate
system that we
care about, the
lab-fixed coordinates.
And they're always
going to be represented
with capital letters.
And there's also the body frame.
And things are in
the body frame.
That's what the
molecule cares about.
And how do things
in the body frame
relate to the laboratory frame?
It's not trivial.
And that's where the real
effort at understanding comes.
And it's kind of trivial
for a diatomic molecule.
But it's far from trivial when
you have a nonlinear molecule,
a molecule with many atoms and
properties of each of the atoms
that somehow combine to give
things that you observe.
And so these two coordinate
systems are very different.
And actually, the solutions
of the rigid rotor
Hamiltonian gives you the
relationship of the body
coordinates to the
laboratory coordinates.
And that's kind of important.
So we'll see how this
develops as I go on.
And I feel quite
passionate about this.
Because one of the things that
I do as an experimentalist is
I observe fully
resolved spectra.
And the big-- the most
information-rich feature
of the spectrum is the
rotational spectrum.
And so it contains a lot
of really good stuff.
OK.
So first of all, the Hamiltonian
is just the kinetic energy.
Because it's a rigid
rotor, it's free.
There's no potential.
But that's the last
nice thing about it.
Because we have to go from
Cartesian to spherical polar
coordinates.
And there are a lot
of unfamiliar things
in this kinetic
energy expression.
And when I write it down,
you're not going to like it.
Unless you're a
mathematician, and you say,
oh, yeah, I want to be able to
solve these kinds of equations.
Because the Schrodinger
equation is,
considering the simplicity
of the problem, terrible.
And except for mathematicians
who just love it
because they know--
oh, I know that equation.
I know how to write down
everything that I care about.
But we care about
different things.
So we want to know the energy
levels of the rigid rotor.
And we also want pictures.
And remember, a picture is a
reduced form of all the details
that you have at your disposal.
And you have to
really sweat to make
sure you understand every detail
of the pictures and the stuff
that you've averaged
over, or you've concealed,
because you don't need it, OK?
All right.
So I'm going to be
generating a lot of pictures.
And one of the things we
want to understand is--
so we have this vector, J.
The J is the angular momentum
of the molecule.
And it's a vector as
opposed to a scalar.
That means it has
three components.
So for this part of the problem
that I've just hidden over
here, that's a one
dimensional problem.
We have a momentum and
a conjugate coordinate
and it's 1D.
This is 3D.
And there's all sorts of
subtle stuff that goes on.
OK.
So we would like to understand
how this vector moves.
Well, there is a question.
I said moves.
We're talking about the
time independent Schrodinger
equation.
Nothing moves.
We can use our concept of
motion from classical mechanics
to describe certain
features of the average
of some quantum
mechanical system.
And so there is
kind of a motion.
But we'll see what that is.
OK.
We have some operators
that we like.
OK.
Total angular momentum,
projection of the angular
momentum on a
laboratory z-axis--
it's kind of hard to draw
capital Z and small z
if you haven't got
anybody nearby.
But anyway, this is
a capital Z. And this
is the thing that's analogous
to the creation and annihilation
operators.
We need them.
And it gives us
a lot of insight.
And that will be the
subject of Monday's lecture.
And so we're going to have
solutions, which are described
by J and m quantum numbers.
And we want to understand
what these things look like.
Where are the nodal surfaces?
The nodal surfaces give
us basically everything
we want to know.
There is the direct correlation
to where the nodes are
and how many of them there are
with these quantum numbers.
That's one of the
important things
you have to come away with.
OK.
In my next lecture
on angular momentum,
I'm going to introduce
a commutation rule,
Ji Jj equals I H bar sum
over K epsilon I Jk Jk.
Isn't that a strange
looking thing?
Because I haven't told
you what this epsilon is.
There's lots of names for it.
It won't help.
Because I'm not going
to talk about it here.
But this is actually the
fundamental definition
of an angular momentum.
And from this
commutator rule, we
can generate all the matrix
elements of angular momentum.
And there's another family
of commutation rules
where we have a component
of angular momentum
and a component of what we
call a spherical tensor.
Any operator can be classified
according to spherical tensor
rank.
And that then determines
all the matrix elements
of that operator.
And so you can imagine that
this is a really powerful way
of approaching stuff.
And what I said before about the
commutation rule of x and P sub
x is that many people regard
that as the foundation
of quantum mechanics.
And this is just an
extension of that.
So there is a way of getting
all quantum mechanics
from a few well-chosen
commutation rules.
And that's really neat.
OK.
Let's get down to business.
So I already drew this.
But I'll draw it again.
Because I'm going
to drop a companion.
OK.
So we have here--
So we have an angular momentum.
And we have the bond axis.
And this angular momentum is
perpendicular to the bond axis.
So if we know something about
how the angular momentum is
distributed in space, we know
something about how the bond
axis is distributed in space.
But it's not trivial.
But once you've learned how
to make those connections,
it's fine.
OK.
So now, let's draw--
So we have a right-handed
coordinate system.
And we have, say,
the vector J. Now,
this is the laboratory frame.
We have J. And we
have a molecule, which
is perpendicular
to J. And we have
the projection of J on the
body axis, on the z-axis,
and that's M.
OK.
So when we talked about
the quantum number
J, which is the length of
this vector, and m, which
is the projection of
that vector on this axis,
that's beginning to be how
we understand how this works.
Because this is
perpendicular to that.
Now, here we have
one of the sins.
So we begin by saying,
well, this is a picture.
And J precesses, or
moves, on a cone around z.
How do we have motion?
This is a time independent
Schrodinger equation.
It's a way of saying, well,
it doesn't matter where J is.
It's more or less
equally distributed
in probability on this cone.
But not an amplitude.
Remember, when we
have something that's
moving in the time independent
Schrodinger equation,
we get oscillations.
But we need a complex
function in order
to have those oscillations.
If we're going to take psi star
psi, there is no complex part.
And you do have
uniform amplitude of J.
And so it's sensible to
say, well, it got that way
because J precesses.
Maybe.
There is something
if you say, well,
maybe if I created a
system at t equal 0
where J was at a
particular position,
and then I let
that thing evolve--
this is not an eigenstate.
It would be a complicated
superposition.
That thing would precess.
And you would observe what
we call polarization quantum
beats.
Now, that's getting
way ahead of things.
But it is helpful to think
about J precessing on this cone.
Because that gives you a
sense that the length of J is
conserved.
And the orientation
about the z-axis is not.
And it's more or less
uniform probability, but not
uniform probability amplitude.
But you don't need that
for a lot of the things.
If you're looking at
the wave function,
yeah, there's going to
be some oscillation.
The real part and
the imaginary part
will oscillate in such a
way that the probability
is constant about that.
I finally realized
that this morning.
So it's not as much
of a lie as you think.
OK.
So this is the picture.
And this is what it looks
like in the laboratory.
And now, I'm going
to prepare you for--
so suppose you had a molecule.
And you have a little person
standing on the molecule frame.
And now, you have somebody out
here observing as the molecule
rotates.
Well, and here's J. All
information that you're
allowed to know from
outside the molecule
comes from the
projection of whatever
is in the molecule
frame on J. And that's
what the vector model does.
It tells you how
to take stuff you
know about the individual
atoms and project it
on the thing that communicates
with the outside world.
There are a couple
of other things
that I'm going to
say about this.
But now, let's get
down to the business
of actually doing a
little bit of the solution
of the Schrodinger equation.
So for our free
rotor, the potential
is r equals r0 theta phi.
And it's equal to
0 if r equals r0.
infinity if it's not.
So this is very much like a
particle in an infinite box.
In fact, you can do a
really cheap solution
if you say, well, let's
consider a particle
in an infinite circular box.
Well, you can solve this problem
just using the de Broglie
wavelength.
And you get that the energy
levels for this circular box
problem go as the
quantum number squared.
And that's almost exactly
like the solutions
to the free rotor.
The difference is the
energies for this go
as the quantum number squared.
And the energies for this
go as the quantum number
times the quantum number plus 1.
It's almost the same.
OK.
So because the potential is
constant as long as r is fixed,
the Hamiltonian is just theta--
OK.
And so we have to understand
this kinetic energy.
For 1D problems,
the kinetic energy
is P squared over 2 mu,
the linear momentum.
I should put a hat on this.
Well, we have motion
in three dimensions,
or two dimensions,
theta and phi.
And so we want to do something.
We want to generate a kinetic
energy Hamiltonian, which
is analogous to this, some
kind of momentum squared
over some kind of a mass.
And so we can go by analogy.
Or we can go back to
classical mechanics.
We know that the orbital
angular momentum is r cross P.
So these are two vectors.
Cross product is a vector.
We know all that stuff.
We know how to write
the cross product
in terms of a matrix
involving unit vectors
and stuff like that.
You've done that before.
OK.
So now, we have an
angular motion, omega.
And we would like to know what
the velocity of the mass points
are on a sphere.
Or if we think of this as just
a particle of mass mu rotating,
then we want to
know its velocity.
And to get from the
angular velocity
to the linear velocity, the
linear velocity is r omega.
So we can say, all
right, knowing--
well, for a vector cross
product, if the two things--
the r and the P--
are always orthogonal, well,
then we just do r times P.
And in fact, for motion
on this sphere, here's r.
And the motion is
always orthogonal to r.
And so we can write that the
angular momentum is m1 r1
squared omega plus m2
r2 squared times omega.
Or it's just I omega.
OK.
And so we can write the
kinetic energy term just
goes as L squared
over 2I where I
is the sum of the individual
masses M sub r I squared.
OK.
So we have an angular
momentum operator,
which is the guts of
the kinetic energy.
OK.
Now, we're thinking Cartesian.
And this is a spherical problem.
And so we want to
go from Cartesian
coordinates to spherical
polar coordinates.
And that's a
non-trivial problem.
And it's also an
extremely boring problem.
And what you get
is also something
that's not terribly rewarding,
except it's the differential
equation you have solve.
So T, when you go to
spherical polar coordinates,
is minus h squared over
2I 1 over sine theta
partial with respect
to theta times
sine theta partial with respect
to theta plus 1 over sine
squared theta second
partial with respect to phi.
So that's the kinetic
energy operator.
So first of all, you say,
what am I going to do?
And the first thing you say
is, separate the variables.
So you do that.
And you do the standard trick
for separating variables.
And you get two differential
equations-- the theta
equation and the phi equation.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: H bar!
ROBERT FIELD: When I wrote it,
I said, why is that not H bar?
OK.
All right, so when you
separate variables,
we have this result--
1 over phi of phi.
This is the phi part
of the equation.
Whoops, yeah, that's right.
m squared is the
separation constant.
So we arrange to have a
differential equation that
depends only on phi and another
that depends only on theta.
And they're equal to each other.
And so we call the thing that
they're equal to a constant.
And we call it m squared.
We like that because m can
be positive or negative.
And the sign of m
determines whether you
have an oscillating function
or an exponential function.
You're all familiar with that.
And so this is the phi equation.
And this one, you
can solve easily.
You know the solution to this.
You could, with a
little bit of thought,
write down the solution and
have normalized functions.
So I'll just do that.
So the phi part of
the solution is--
it's not the order in
which I wrote my notes--
1 over the square root of 2
pi times e to the i m phi.
And m is equal to 0 plus
and minus 1 plus and minus
2 et cetera.
Quantization comes
from imposition
of what we call periodic
boundary conditions.
The wave function has to
be the same for phi and phi
plus 2 pi and phi plus 4 pi.
And so that gives quantization.
So this is the phi part.
That's simple.
It's wonderful.
We understand that perfectly.
And one of the nice things
about the vector model
is mostly that's what
you're focused on.
So immediately, we can
draw some pictures.
And we can look at the
nodes in the xy plane.
So m equals 0,
there are no nodes.
m equals 1, first of all,
let's draw where phi is 0.
So this is phi.
And so there can be a
nodal plane like that.
And there could be a
And already, you know this
looks like an S orbital.
And this looks like a Px
orbital and a Py orbital.
And then we could also have--
yeah, m equals 2, we could
have this, and this, and that--
no node, one node, two nodes.
I'm sorry, yeah.
What am I doing here?
This is one node.
I have to be a little
bit more careful here.
So what I wrote down
is not true here.
There are going to be two nodes.
So they're probably
like this and like that.
But it's clear that what I
have in my handwritten notes--
I'm not sure what the
printed notes say.
But there are going
to be two nodes.
And so immediately, you
know something about--
if you draw a reduced
picture and you
show the nodal structure
in the xy plane,
you can tell what the projection
of the angular momentum quantum
number is, which is
really important.
There's the other
differential equation.
And that's the theta
And that is complicated.
It is an exactly solved
differential equation.
But one of the
things it gives you,
which is easily memorized--
remembered, I'm sorry--
is that the energy levels have--
where this is the
overlying momentum.
So you can solve this.
And you can get
the eigenenergies.
And the eigenenergies
do not depend on m.
They only depend on
the L quantum number.
And they have this nice form.
OK.
Now, in my notes and
in all the textbooks,
there are these horrendously
beautiful detailed expressions
of the solution, the
mathematical form
to the solution of
the theta equation.
And it's the Legendre equation.
And there's Legendre
polynomials.
And remember, with the harmonic
oscillator, I told you,
you don't ever want to
look at these things.
The computer will look at them.
And if you have
integrals, the computer
will know how to
do those integrals.
Because you told it how.
And you don't have to
keep that in your head.
You've got better things to do
with your limited attention.
So there is a solution.
And it has a form,
which I have decided
that I won't talk about.
Because you get much more
insight into real problems
from the vector model.
Now, the vector
model is really only
marginally useful for
a diatomic molecule
in an electronic state, which
you don't know about yet, which
is called sigma sigma plus,
where there is no angular
momentum associated
with the electron
and when there is no
angular momentum associated
with the nuclei.
So this is just
practice for real life
when you have to understand
other things about what is
living in the molecular frame.
But this is hard enough to
understand completely that it's
a worthwhile investment.
And you will be doing
most of the understanding
of more complicated
problems on your own
if you ever do anything
with diatomic molecules
or polyatomic molecules.
And so, OK.
So what is the vector model?
Well, the things we want to
know about the vector model
is, how long is J?
So if we have a state with
J and m quantum numbers,
how long is the vector
associated with J?
And what is the angle--
what is the projection of
J on the laboratory z-axis?
So we want to know
the length of J.
And we want to know the
projection of J on z.
OK.
And we want to know the angle
between the z-axis and J.
That's the beginning
of a picture.
And again, we stick
with this idea that J--
so here's the z-axis.
And J precesses about z.
And here is an angle
we want to know.
This theta is a different
theta from the theta in--
in fact, I should call it alpha.
OK.
So some things we know--
we know that the eigenvalues
of the rigid rotor equation
are this.
And we know that Jz
operator operating on y Lm
gives H bar m y Lm.
And J squared operating on y Lm
gives H bar squared J J plus 1.
So what do we do with
these two things?
Well, one is to say, all
right, the length of J
is going to be the square root--
times y Lm.
So the length of J is
going to be the square root
of H bar squared J J plus 1.
So that becomes H bar and
approximately J plus 1/2.
Because the square
root of J J plus 1
is almost exactly J plus 1/2.
When you get really
high J, it's exactly.
At low J, It's a little
bit less than exact.
So we know the
length of J is this.
And we know the length
of m is H bar m.
The length of J z is H bar m.
So now, we know that
this is H bar m.
And this is H bar
times J plus 1/2.
And so this is alpha.
So we know how to calculate
the cosine of alpha.
So the cosine of
alpha is equal to H
bar m over H bar J
plus 1/2, or m over J--
oh, right, plus
1/2, really small.
So the angle, the
cosine of the angle
that j makes with the
z-axis is m over J.
And all of a sudden,
now, we have lengths
of things and angles of things.
And we can do all
sorts of stuff.
Remember, what we care
about is, if this is J,
the body axis is like that.
So we now know
where the body axis
is relative to the laboratory.
So we have the body axis
is perpendicular to J.
And so we can then calculate
where everything is.
All right, so special cases--
if m is equal to
plus or minus J, then
what does that mean
for this picture?
Well, we have the z-axis.
And we have J. And J is almost
exactly along the z-axis.
It would be exactly along if
there wasn't this plus 1/2.
And so what that
means is the bond
axis is almost exactly
rotating in the xy plane.
So if we choose m
equals plus or minus J,
the molecule is rotating
in the xy plane.
That's kind of nice to know.
The other easy
case is m equals 0.
If m equals 0, J is
perpendicular to the z-axis.
And so the body axis
is in the yz plane.
Or if we're coming around
here, it's in the xz plane.
So we have xz yz.
And together, what
it says is the body
axis is more along z
than along anything else.
That's a lot of insight.
And so we can go to our friendly
extreme cases, special cases.
And we could say,
where's the body axis?
In the laboratory,
which is where
we're making the observations.
That should make you happy.
Because there's
no equations here.
There's just a lot of pictures
that you can understand
and develop your intuition.
Now, I want a blackboard.
OK.
Suppose you have a
laboratory in which you
can make a molecular beam.
And that's easy enough to do.
You squirt molecules
out of a pinhole.
And you have some
kind of an aperture.
And so you have a directed flow
of molecules in one direction.
And you could also
say, all right,
I'm going to do
something with my laser.
And I'm going to make
the molecules, which
are like a helicopter,
in other words,
the molecular axis is
rotating in a circle
about the propagation axis
of the beam, so a helicopter.
And we can also do this.
And so these are two ways
that you can prepare molecules
in this beam.
And you could say, oh, I've
got a whole bunch of molecules
that are not in the beam.
And these molecules
are going to collide
with the molecules outside
the beam and get scattered.
Well, which one is going
to be scattered more?
The one that sweeps out a
big volume or the one that
sweeps out something only
essentially one dimension?
That's insight.
There's lots of
other things, too.
Now, let's do something
which is actually
slightly exam relevant.
Suppose we have a
diatomic molecule
which is positive on one end
and negative on the other, OK?
And we're going to
apply an electric field.
And if the electric field
is in this direction
and the molecule is doing this,
the molecule doesn't care.
But if the electric field
is in that direction
and the molecule is doing
this, the energy levels--
the energy goes up and down
as the molecule rotates.
Well, how is that?
The molecule was
free to precess.
And we knew the amplitude
along this axis.
But if there's some angle
dependence, what we're doing
is we're mixing
in a different J.
And so that's telling you that,
if you apply an electric field,
there will be a Stark effect.
And it will affect the m
equals 0 levels differently
from the m equals J levels.
Now, I'm not going to tell you
which one is more affected.
But it's clear that
one is hardly affected.
And the other is
profoundly affected.
And that gives rise to a
splitting of the energy
levels in an
electric field, which
depends on J at m in a way
that you would recognize.
Time to quit.
I did what I was
hoping I could do.
Now, there is some stuff
at the end of the notes
which is standard textbook
material about polar plots
of the wave functions.
These polar plots are useful.
But most of the time, when
you first encounter them,
you have no idea what they
mean, except that they
express where the nodes are.
Now, you want to go
back and you want
to actually think about
what these polar plots mean
and whether you can use
them as an auxiliary
to this vector picture.
OK.
So I will then lecture,
and it's exam relevant,
on commutation rules on Monday.
And then have a good weekend.